hi everyone and welcome to this
presentation where i'm going to talk
about
a new online problem and this problem
will also motivate some
purely mathematical questions related to
metrics based extensions
this is joint work with sebastian bubeck
knife bookbinder and mark selker
and i am christian kester and we call
this new problem metrical service
systems with transformations
and it is based on the problem called
metrical service systems
which is one of the known and most
fundamental
problems in online algorithms so in this
problem there is a metric space
m and some initial point p0 in this
metric space
and now at any discrete time step some
subset of the metric space is defined as
the feasible set so
this set which we denote by a t is
revealed
at time t and then the algorithm has to
choose a point
in this feasible set so if the green one
is the first feasible set then
the algorithm state has to go to this
set
then the next feasible status set is
revealed
again the algorithm has to move and so
on
and the cost of the algorithm is defined
as simply the total
distance traveled by the state of the
algorithm
and now we say that the competitive
ratio of an algorithm is a row
if the cost of the algorithm is at most
row times the optimal cost on any
possible input
and what's known about this problem is
that the competitive ratio is linear in
the size of the metric space
for deterministic algorithms and for
randomized algorithms
it follows from what's known about metal
grid task systems
that the competitive version is probably
logarithmic in the size of the metric
space
there are some important special cases
of metrical service systems that have
been studied extensively
so two examples are convex body chasing
which
was studied especially intensively in
the
recent couple of years so here the
metric space is a vector space
and every set a t is convex and it was
shown
in the two best papers at soda last year
that the competitive ratio is
d so the dimension of the vector space
another special case is the k server
problem
and there are also several other
problems that fall into this
mss framework so let's look more closely
at the
k server problem now so in this problem
there's also a metric space
but now there are k servers in this
metric space
and points of the metric space are
requested one by one
and whenever a point is requested one of
the servers has to be selected to go to
the point
and then the next point is requested
again one of the servers has to go to
the request
and the cost is defined as the total
distance traveled by all the servers so
at first sight it may not be obvious why
this falls into this mss framework
because we have k servers and not just
one
and moreover the requests here are
single points rather than sets
but the the reason why this does fall
into the msx framework is that
if we look at instead of the metric
space m at the
configuration space as the metric space
for the
medical service systems problems so the
configuration space
contains all sets of size k which
corresponds to server configurations so
the
locations of the k servers now we can
model the k server requests at some
point r
by the feasible set that contains all
the configurations
that contain the um the point r
so this is why it is an mss and yeah
which
what i didn't say is that this
configuration space itself is also a
metric space so the metric on
m induces a metric on the configuration
space
so even though many problems fall into
this
mss class there are still limitations
to metroid service systems one is that
it's impossible to change the state of
the algorithm without incurring cost
so in particular therefore meta reserve
systems
fail to capture more dynamic
environments where maybe the
state of the argument changes for
reasons that are outside of the
algorithm's control
for instance resources could appear and
disappear
and we might not want to charge any cost
for this
so this is not possible in metrical
service systems and also
metagross service systems don't capture
a problem that's called the k
taxi problem so
let's look at the k taxi problem first
in this problem it's
very similar to the case server problem
we have k servers in a metric space
each request is a pair of points stdt
corresponding to passenger requests for
a taxi
and to service such a request we have to
select one of the taxis that moves first
to st
and then to dt and then the next
request arrives and so on and what's
important here is that the cost is
defined as
not the total distance traveled by the
taxis but just the
overhead distance traveled by the taxis
so the distance traveled
while not carrying a passenger the
reason for defining the cost in this way
is that well first of all during the
time when you
do carry a passenger you wanna you're
not really paying costs but if anything
you're making money
but uh more importantly this distance
traveled with a passenger
is the same for any algorithm so
therefore it makes sense to exclude it
from the cost
and only focus on the overhead distance
so yeah so we would here pay to go to
the passenger but then
we don't pay to bring the passenger to
the destination
so to model these more general problems
including the k taxi problem
we define now metric service systems
with transformations
as follows so it's similar to metric or
service systems we have a metric space
again
and some initial point b0 in the metric
space which is the
state of the algorithm and now at every
time step
we receive not just a feasible set a t
but instead transformation between two
sets
a t and b t and now the algorithm has to
choose a point in the domain
of the transformation and then the new
state of the algorithm will be the image
of this point
under this transformation so if this is
the first transformation we receive the
algorithm has to go
to the set 80 and now the transformation
is applied
and the point correspond the
corresponding point in bt will be the
new state of the algorithm
and the algorithm suffers cost now only
for going
to the state in 80 and there is no cost
in encourage when the transformation is
applied
so why does this problem model the
k taxi problem well it's similar to the
way that we equipped model
bk server problem by metro service
systems
we look again at the configuration space
so
again the sets of k locations
the k taxi locations this configuration
space is now the metric space
for tmss and the taxi request from a
point st to a point dt
can be modeled by the transformation
whose domain
is the set of all configurations that
contain the point st
and such a configuration is then mapped
to the corresponding
configuration where the point st is
removed
and the point dt is added to the
configuration
and it's not hard to see that this then
indeed captures the k
taxi problem so in this example of the k
taxi problem
one can see that the transformation is
in fact in isometry
and this case of isometries is an
important special case that we will
pay particular attention to and yeah but
there are also other
classes of transformations that we will
have a look at
um but yeah let's first focus on the
case of isometries
so meaning that the distance between two
points in the domain
stays the same after the transformation
is applied
so as a first example let's look at
convex body chasing with isometry
transformations
so any transformation is a convex
well it's an isometry between two
isometric convex sets
let's say in the euclidean space here
it's
the case that any isometry is a
combination of a rotation reflection and
translation well possibly reflection
and what this means is that we can
therefore extend any isometry
between these two convex sets to a
global isometry of the entire
vector space and therefore the isometry
is not really doing anything we can just
rotate the coordinate system as well
and then the isometry just amounts to
renaming of the points of the space
so therefore the competitive ratio of
convex body chasing with isometries is
the same as the
competitive ratio of normal convex body
chasing
here's another example let's say we have
the circle on the circle
it's also true that any isometry
of of a subset to another subset is
either a rotation or a
reflection so for instance this isometry
here that maps the orange points to the
green points
this extends to global isometry of the
entire metric space it's a reflection in
this case
so again it's just a renaming of the
points of the space therefore having
these isometries doesn't increase the
difficulty of the problem at all
here's a case where isometries do affect
the problem
and the competitive ratio so if we have
equally spaced points on a line
now um these partial isometries
do not in general extend to global
isometries
but still it's a fairly easy example
because what we can do is that we extend
the line
to a circle by adding more points to it
and now we can
apply the logic from before and
therefore we have the competitive ratio
uh of the two n minus two point circle
as an upper bound for the competitive
ratio
what so so the competitive ratio of
network service systems without
transformation on this circle is an
upper bound
for the competitive ratio of metrical
service systems with transformation
with isometry transformations on the n
equally based points online
so this sort of suggests a general
recipe
to always extend the metric space so
that we can extend the partial
isometries to global ones
so the first question we should ask
therefore is
is this always possible so is it
possible that for any metric space m
we can always find a super space such
that any partial isometry
by which i mean isometry between two
subsets of m
extends to an automorphism of m hat so
automorphism
means a global isometry from m hat onto
itself
and the answer is that it is possible
and it was shown relatively recently in
the mathematics literature
that this can be done such that m hat is
a finite matrix space
provided that m is also a finite metric
space
so what this means is that tmss on space
m
with isometric transformation um reduces
to the well-studied metrical server
systems problems on
m hat and therefore the competitive
ratio
is at most polyglogarithmic in the size
of m hat
then the follow-up question of course is
what is the size of the head
in particular is it possible to bound
the size of a head
as a function of the size of m so is
there some function b which we would
call the blow up function such that
for for any metric space m b
well b of the size of m is an upper
bound on the
size of the extended matrix space m hat
and the answer to this is we don't know
and yeah so this is one of the main open
problems that we are posing in this
paper
because the positive answer for instance
say
a an exponential uh function
uh yeah like if b is an exponential
function then it would mean that there's
a polynomial
competitive ratio for tmss with isometry
transformations
let's see now how these ideas can be
applied to the
k taxi problem so we're going to
get an algorithm with competitive ratio
that's polynomial in
the size of the metric space and log k
and the ideas are as follows so first of
all
by applying standard techniques we can
assume
that the metric space for the k taxi
problem is in fact a tree
this is following from some uh
well-known embedding uh
theorems and it's losing a factor log n
but
uh yeah we only want to be
polynomial in in the size of the metric
space anyway so we can
lose this and
now on on this tree we can encode a taxi
configuration
by a vector in this space so it assigns
to every vertex u and number x u which
denotes the number of taxis located in
the sub tree rooted at you
and for this encoding we can now also
encode
uh taxi request from sd2dt as follows
so it's defined on the set of
vectors that correspond to valid toxic
configurations
with at least one tuxedo st
and what it would do with such a vector
x is that it subtracts
one from every unsystem vertex of the
s point s t and it adds one
to every ancestor vertex of the
destination of the request
and it's not hard to see that this
indeed transforms
the configuration in the way that's
correct to model this k taxi request
and um so so now if if v was just a
single point instead of a vertex
instead of the set of all vertices then
we would we could just apply the ideas
from before where we
extended the the line to a circle but
also in multiple dimensions we can do
this
and circle in multiple dimensions really
means that
we're going to have to have the taurus
metric so every dimension instead of
going from
0 to k now goes from 0 to 2k
and we have the torus metric on the
space
and now it's true that any such map
which is in particular a translation
extends to a global isomorphism of
this extended space so therefore the k
taxi problem on m
reduces to the metrical service systems
problem
on this extended space and in particular
the competitive ratio is poly
logarithmic
in the size of this space and therefore
it's polynomial in the size of
m and log k
so let's return now to the more general
tmss problem
and the case when the the
transformations are not
isometries so then
if they are not isometries the situation
is a lot more difficult
so here's an example with a five-point
metric space these
five green dots and the blue dot is the
online
location the orange one the offline
location
now suppose we get this transformation
which
clearly is not an isometry
now the online item has to select one of
these points in the middle that's in the
domain of the transformation
and say for example it goes to this one
then the offline algorithm
could go to the other point in the
domain
so this part incurs some tiny
movement costs for both the online and
offline algorithm because these points
are very close together in the middle
but now the transformation is applied
and when the transformation is applied
no additional cost is incurred by
definition of the problem
but the two online and offline locations
have been pulled apart
and this can now be abused by a request
sequence so if the next request forces
the online algorithm
to move all the way to the offline
algorithm then we see that the online
algorithm
pays a lot more movement cost than the
offline algorithm and we can
issue another relocate another
transformation that
moves the two points to the middle again
for free
so we've seen here that the online
algorithm pays a lot more than the
offline and therefore we can
get arbitrarily large lower ones on the
competitive ratio here
even on smaller spaces of five points or
even less point size
um it's possible to do this
and yeah of course we can repeat this as
often as we want
um yeah and therefore we get this lower
bound here so but what this really
relies on is that these transformations
uh pull these two locations of online
and offline very far apart
what is what would happen if if this
can't be the case
so say the transformations are always uh
non-expanding so there are one libgets
so as an example of this let's look at
chasing
contracting convex bodies so
what i mean by this is that the metric
space is a vector space
and every transformation is a
contraction between two convex sets
and uh if you want to test your
intuition then
feel free to pause the video for a
moment and have a guess of what you
expect the competitive ratio to be like
would it be harder than
convex body chasing or would it have the
same difficulty
well it turns out that maybe
surprisingly
the competitive ratio is infinite in
this case
and the reason it's infinite even in the
two-dimensional plane the reason
why we cannot just use the known
algorithms for convex body chasing and
and to modify them slightly
is that they rely on the fact that the
work function is convex
and this property will be destroyed if
we insert these contractions here
and yeah it is in indeed possible to
construct a lower bound showing that
there is no
competitive algorithm for this problem
so it may seem that we are doomed
but what's what's a bit special here
about this problem is that the metric
space contains infinitely many points
if we have a metric space of finitely
many points so let's say m is an
endpoint matrix space then
we can we can get a competitive
algorithm for the case of contractions
and even more generally
when all the transformations are alpha
elephants
so here we get a competitive ratio
that's roughly
alpha to the n if alpha is large enough
or otherwise
yeah six to the n this is a
deterministic algorithm
and there's also a lower bound that's um
well essentially matching if alpha is
large enough up to
some factor 2 in the
in front of the alpha here
and the lower bound is even working for
randomized algorithms
however note that if alpha is one so in
the case of non-expanding
isometries um non-non-expanding
transformations
then this lower bound is just one so
it's it doesn't give us anything
of course there's also the low one that
exists for medical service systems but
still there's a large
gap in the case of um
contractions and in particular also in
the case of
isometries between these upper and lower
bounds
so i'm going to show the ideas of this
upper bound proof
it consists of three steps the first
step is that we
define an ultrametric d head on
on the points of the metric space and
the head is going to be
a distortion of the true metric so it's
within a factor alpha plus one to the n
minus 2 of this metric and it will be
such that
any function that's alpha philips with
respect to d
is a contraction with respect to d hat
so we show that it's possible
to define such an ultrametric on any
finite metric
and alpha metric what this really means
is that it's a
special type of tree now the next step
is that we extend this tree this
ultrametric tree to
one that's completely symmetric so every
vertex
like any two vertices of the same level
have the same number of children
and the point of this now is that in
this symmetric ultrametric tree
we can adapt the analysis of the work
function algorithm for mss
to the case of tmss with
with these contractions so if it was
not contractions but isometries then
this would be
relatively simple because the isometries
extend to global isometries
in the case of contractions we make use
of some
properties that these ultrametrics have
that allow us to still analyze the work
function algorithm
so we lose the alpha plus one to the n
minus two factor in the competitive
ratio in the first step because this is
the error of the ultrametric compared to
the true metric
and we lose another factor of
roughly 2 to the n minus 1 because
we add so many more points in in the
second step where we extend the matrix
by
space
and uh yeah with that i'm coming to the
end so i'm just going to mention the
main
open problems so first of all what is
the competitive ratio of
tmss for interesting families of metric
spaces or transformations
so we think that isometries and
contractions are particularly
interesting transformations here because
we have
well first of all there are there are
natural classes
they occur in for instance the k taxi
problem
and the gaps between the upper and lower
ones that we have are very large here
and then there's this purely
mathematical question
given some finite metric space m what's
the minimal cardinality
of an extension m hat such that each
partial isometry on m
extends to automorphism on m hat
for this second question we also give
some partial answers for special cases
so for instance if m is an ultrametric
or if it's a general metric but we have
swap isometries so just swapping two
points
then the blow up here is at most
exponential
and in fact this is also tight for both
of these cases
but we don't have we don't know any
metric space where there's a larger
lower bound
and we also don't know an upper bound of
a similar form for general metric spaces
so this would be quite
interesting and i think of could be of
independent
interest so thanks a lot for watching
and goodbye